وهاي حالتنا يعني زي ما انت شايفه احنا
مرض تس ما فيش حدا مدور علينا لا ادويه
ولا غذاء ولا اي حاجب فلسطين المصري طلعنا
من خانيونس جينا هنا وصلنا تقريبا الساعه
10 ونص بالليل نمنا بالشارع يعني كمان ما
كناش معنا شي نعمل خيام وحده هدم اللي
بناخدها يعني انا رحت قبل يومين احط وحده
دم دمي خمسه بكيلي الدكتور يا عمي كلي طب
من وين اجيب اكل تعبنا كفي عن جدب يعني
الفول ممنوع اكله صرت اكله
ممنوع اكله ممنوع من عن بات صرت اكله
تسديد جوع طب انا مش ملاقي شي طب ه من
الصبح حتى ماكلتش قشي البني ادم الطبيعي
مش قادر يعيش اي حال المرضى يعني اختي ه
شوفي رجليها ه الجد صاره يعني ما بشوفها
في الليل بسبك عليها كمان يعني انا كل
فتره بتجيني حاله اغماق
وخايفه خايف اني اغيب ودي روح اهلي فيا طب
لا شهيده حصلي اسمي شهيده في الاول اخير
شهيده والمريض شهيد برضو يعني انا 37 سنه
في المرض انا الحين انحار من العلاج
بالخارج
ليش ليش مش من حق اني اروح اتعالج هذ
التحوي الي لحالي المرافق ابويا مكتوب اسم
المرافق هذ المفروض انا المفروض زمان
عامله العمليه اصلا يوم عن يوم الشريان
بالضيق وانا زارعه كمان جهاز
هنا انا ما بديش اسوق حالتي انا من حق اني
اسافر كمان واتعالج الكف اللي احنا
فيه